most humans who could ever exist never
will think I've heard you say if there's
been more humans that have not come into
existence than do exist by far and so
the fact that you exist at all
is against stupefying odds of who gets
born and who does not any moment you
spend squandering those moments you are
alive does disrespect to all those who
will never even be born
I believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves to create
the life that we really want and I want
to help give you the tools to make that
happen
I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense
[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
today's guest is someone that is about a
million times more intelligent than me
and I'm not gonna lie it was a little
intimidating Neil deGrasse Tyson
astrophysicist not even sure what that
means but look he is amazing and his
depth of knowledge is not only about
stars and space and where did we come
from and you know Adams and nucleuses
and subatomic particles and a whole
bunch of other words I can't think of
because they're too big for me but we
talked about religion and you know that
was something that really surprised me
because look he's a scientist and
scientists and science and religion
don't really go together but he he knows
a lot about it and we talked about that
we talked about why he knows a lot about
it
we we talked about another interesting
topic that was fascinating and that's
just the trajectory of being 1% more
intelligent so chimpanzees are 1% less
intelligent than humans
so what's 1% warm what's 1% more of that
and then of course I asked the ultimate
question do you believe in aliens so I
hope you have an amazing time listening
to this and learn because I sure did
well I became a huge fan with cosmos Oh
excellent why are you like a few years
ago okay I put that on I was like that
looks interesting and I've always been
blown away if you're not something's
wrong I mean I used to I used to
remember I used to sit there as a kid
nice to look up and I said I was like it
goes on forever yeah that just gives me
a headache at the pure thought of it and
it still gives me a headache to think
that montt that idea of like it just
keeps going and there's no one but there
has been and if there isn't and what's
the end I mean so here's the thing our
senses are five traditional senses were
forged sort of in the plains of Africa
where there is no need to think about
know or understand infinity we have no
capacity for that it's our mathematics
that shows us that it's real it's our
observations of the universe that show
the infinitude of it all and you just
got a deal we want answers but you can't
be a scientist this is the interesting
paradox scientists want answers to but
we are completely content steeped in
ignorance because it's the ignorance
that attracts us not the answers to fit
to figure it out to figure it out
journey it's the journey to that
frontier I tweeted recently just cuz it
came upon me very funny oh thank you
that as the area of our knowledge grows
so too does the perimeter of our
ignorance hmm and so right so with the
scientific you're saying a bigger center
gets the bigger the outside outside
outside the perimeter you know why it's
like age it makes me feel like a
gigantic Fortin you because you know
more you know more of what you don't
know that's what it is and here's the
problem here's a prevailing problem in
society it's knowing enough to think
you're right but not enough to know that
you're wrong
I have to do this with you a lot of tea
that's insightful okay I'm saying okay
yep
you learned a little bit about something
and you say I got this yeah I got this
well maybe you don't but you don't know
enough to know that you don't write you
have to learn more to realize you
actually didn't know so the great
challenge for us all to repeat the
phrase is knowing enough to think you're
right but not knowing enough to know
that you're wrong and that gets a lot of
people in trouble because they rise up
thinking they got the answers and so as
a scientist there are answers we have we
know a lot about how the world works but
our job is to hack our way a cutting
through the brush and ramble to the
frontier that boundary between what is
known and unknown in the universe and
when you stand there and look out into
the abyss you can't fear that that has
to attract you right and and so we we
celebrate not knowing I have a whole
video see what do you mean celebrate we
don't know it's like hey where's the
next place where we don't know it I got
over there oh my gosh or someone makes
an observation or discovery that we
don't understand we don't understand it
let's have a party let's have a
conference and let's have bring all our
best ideas to the table and we'll talk
about it it'll get excited about it yeah
that's that's that is it so so if you
have to have answers yeah I think that's
in white that a religion kind of does
that religion gives you answers to all
manner of things what happens after you
die what happens you know your spirit
your this and people read it they got
the answer and it gives them certain
comfort I think I hear here's how one of
these conversations has played out
before so a religious person might ask
me so how the universe get here looking
at the Big Bang and that describes
everything like from that first moment
and then and then they'll say
but what was around before the Big Bang
and I'll say I don't know that's what we
got top people working on it well they
have to be something is there we're
blind
thank you yes yes
we got singularity people working on
that they call string theorists hmm so
you were right on the button there but
they'll say there had to be something I
said I don't know maybe there was
nothing I don't know we're working up
they had to be something that's God
right so they got the answer yeah
so we want to answer they insist they
say God and then they go home and they
can sleep well at night
whereas a scientist on the frontier
hardly ever gets a good night's know if
it was distracted by the unknown you
said that the thing that scares you most
is not knowing the right question to ask
it's not that I don't wanna say it
scares me but it it it intrigues me
so it feels to me like this edge of the
frontier that you're talking about is
scary because you don't know what to ask
next but it's exciting and so if
something excites you right
you should dive in it's like how I felt
about like for me last year I hosted the
ESPYs and I was scared shitless like I
was like I'm not funny
I'm not presentable you don't see it I
can't do this and I was like but I
really want to but I was scared but I
was excited and I had to finally fight
off the scared enough to say yes because
I feel like if something scares you and
excites you somewhat the same you should
go with it
you should dive in I think there's deep
wisdom there and often you respect the
thing you fear the most and you'll you
will delicately navigate let which you
fear the most so you might be giving
that the most attention the most care
the most concern so yeah so for me
people ask that that point about the
question I don't yet know to ask is a
follow-on to the question what is the
question you want to see most answered
and the
I've got through something we don't know
what dark matter is and dark energy and
how you go from organic molecules to
self-replicating life that happens
sometime in the early Earth under plenty
I got I got a list of questions but
that's not what keeps me awake at night
mm-hmm
it's the question I don't yet know to
ask because we don't yet stand in the
Vista that allows me to see that
question in the first place and it's
discoveries that continue the continuum
it's the continual parade of discoveries
that don't simply move forward but they
ascend to give you higher and higher
ground to see farther into the universe
and recognize things that you didn't
even know to ask that that I'd lay awake
an iPad and so one of my regrets the day
I die I'll say to myself I wonder what
questions we don't even know to ask yet
and I would have died before I find out
have you answered some life do you feel
like you've kind of know so I had a
predictions a few decades ago I gave and
watch you in Indianapolis upon here when
your speaking engagement whenever one of
yours one of your tours yeah yeah yeah
news clippings from what was the title
of your tour called a mighty Biff is it
reason that's it excellent yep my sister
and I wouldn't watched you that's a
little thank you thank you
so the so was I saying be what have you
learned like what it what do you feel
like are there some questions that
you're like some decades ago in a
research paper I made a prediction that
there ten times as many galaxies in the
universe as our catalogs then record it
and it was some little bit controversial
not deeply controversial but just know
that we don't think so this sort of
telescope show decades later we found
ten times as many galaxies how many
galaxies do we think there are in the
universe
this is silicon so you're so what's a
bazillion what's bazillion times 10 10
bazillions bajillion so the numbers are
fluctuating right but anywhere between a
hundred billion and a half a trillion
galaxies or really of all different
sizes are in the universe and you might
say well how come you don't know it more
precisely not that you ask that but you
might be thinking it between 100 billion
and 500 billion which is a half a
trillion that sounds like you don't
really know the answer however here's
something that hardly anyone appreciates
about astrophysics the range of things
in size temperature pressure is so huge
that if you get something and you're off
by a factor of two you're doing good
yeah yeah because you could have been
off by a factor of a thousand in either
direction some would say okay I'm taller
than you
alright someone said well he brought you
a lot or she thought not compared to
this building out there not appeared to
a Paramecium so to the building and the
Paramecium we're the same size as far as
they're concerned because they're so far
in that range from that size difference
so in the universe there's such a big
range in everything we're content if we
get some within a fact or two then we
move on you know what size thing you
just made me think of that I think is
like blows my mind is that please
clarify all those you know I'm generally
going on but if you took and condensed
all of the atoms down to actual matter
like all the people on earth that's the
size of an apple or something like yeah
yeah so it's kind of blows my math okay
let me let me complete the mind-blowing
please dimension of this okay there's a
guy named first Rutherford he was a New
Zealand physicist and he wondered how
much
there's a nucleus an electron so he took
gold and hammered it very thin gold has
this you this unique property that you
can hammer it's so thin it's almost just
a few atoms thick across that so that's
why this gold flower on there in ancient
times because they can stay together not
only hands together but you can you can
form it you can form it and you don't
have to use very much of it okay and you
can cover things and the whole thing's
very shiny gold you've used real gold
okay so that you can make it Sophia it's
not that expensive okay so that's why
gold is good for it's usually made of
what's holds like for I'm gold-plated
came from exactly exactly exactly
so you he made a gold foil and just sort
of dangled it there and then he fired
particles mm-hmm into this go forth and
he wanted to see how many of them would
get stopped or ricocheted off her will
pass through he expected most to be just
ricocheted up this is you can't see
through the gold one right it is solid
as far as your concern right and 99.99%
of all particles went through as though
nothing was there god I love science
okay well I'm not even done yet mom and
he he freaked out what's going on here
maybe did the particle go in and then
get stopped and in a step another one
come out maybe it's just a transfer
thing know it matter was mostly empty
and he concluded that the space between
the nucleus of an atom and the electrons
is this vast chasm of nothingness and it
is rumored that the next morning when he
woke up he alone knew how empty matter
was he was afraid to step onto the floor
sure to be up in a high-rise ending on
earth lest he fall through the atoms
down to the basement because science
once you know you know you can't know
can't unknow you can't unknow so now if
you want to compress
everything if you want to compress yeah
all the people in the world can press us
down and and fill in all those gaps yeah
yeah I have to do the calculation but
Apple so maybe a maybe a plum yeah we
all just fit into that little ball of
the human race would fit into that
volume so what the hell are we what are
we well I so I think you're over valuing
the the matter part yet matter matters
but the space you occupy includes space
nothing wrong with that
so we're just Stardust we've always been
Stardust and I think the fact that we
have this empty space it's what allows
atoms to do their thing if all that
everything were collapsed into the dense
matter of a nucleus you wouldn't have
atoms its atoms that make molecules and
its molecules that make life so we
should be glad that atoms simply here's
what happens I have one atom here a
nucleus Anna and the electrons flitting
about have another atom in electrons and
the electrons intersect and bind the two
atoms together and you get a molecule if
I get h2o is it because we're like it
being energy cooped up in an atom yeah
there's energy everywhere everywhere
that's why not to make another kind of
leap here in this conversation but we're
going everywhere I think it's
legitimately gotta leap into this so you
can calculate how much chemical energy
is in your body calculate that and that
energy came from the fact that you made
food your whole life food has energy it
also tastes good but it has energy and
you absorb that energy so that you can
build your when you're growing you can
build your body from childhood to
adulthood you in addition you use the
energy just to live to maintain your
body temperature right now the air is
like 73 degrees in this room okay
your body temperature if you're human is
98 and
after green you are sustaining a 36 the
26 degree temperature difference between
your body in this air because of burning
energy in this instant because the
moment you stop burning energy the
moment you die actually this reminds me
of a story about my dog a long time ago
might my dog couldn't maintain his body
temperature anymore and that was a sign
that we knew Wow well so that means your
your your physiology is breaking down
and you can maintain your body's normal
functions and that's a very important
function for a warm-blooded creature to
maintain that body temperature but I can
tell you this if you died then all that
metabolism stops the metabolism is the
converting the the chemical energy into
kinetic energy because you move then
into thermal energy to keep your body
warm so no watch what happens that
instant your body begins to cool cools
down to what temperature what's on its
way towards air temperature that's why
if you go in a funeral parlor if there's
an open casket and you have any people
who actually touches the dead body
what's the first thing everybody says
about it's cold yeah it's actually not
cold it's the same temperatures the
table as the chair as the floor it's the
same campus is that you're not
accustomed to touching skin at table
temperature because skin is 98 point but
well it's usually a degree or so a
little cooler than your inner
temperature but high 90s so the energy
of your body is there and it's working
and it's maintaining your body
temperature against this and so so all
I'm saying is when you die so this is
why I have told people when I die I
don't want to be cremated oh do you know
what happens when you cream in you break
apart the molecules of your body and
release the energy that's what burning
is that's what that is
there's energy in these molecules you
burn it you break it apart your releases
heat so now
your body is ash hmm with no source of
heat left in it and it it it when it
heated the atmosphere and the atmosphere
radiated to space nothing wrong with
that so your body's energy has now
escaped escaped to space so wait a
minute if you bury me however hmm that
same molecular energy it breaks apart by
action of microbes they dine upon my
body I have an energy source available
to it's how you can eat a steak and have
the steak give you energy that's the
future we're dead I mean you want to
still give after your death thank you
that's so kind of you that's spent my
life dining upon flora and fauna right
that is have given their lives for my
sustenance the least I could do on death
is to return the favor to a next
generation of flora and fauna so that
they can thrive in their own lives
through it I have mine so it leads to
this question where do we go when we die
well so I can answer that question as a
so I guess who what are we is the first
question right we have to answer what
are we and then we have to answer where
do we go there that fertile topic but
before I get there I just want to say
scientifically I know I can but like I
said your body has a energy that you've
accumulated your whole life nope all
these molecules you go in the dirt all
that energy is recovered and it goes
back to all the other life-forms far as
science is concerned you're done you're
done so now you're asking but how about
me my spirit energy my soul my
everything that I am yeah well we could
turn to neuroscience okay they're parts
of your brain that are you they're parts
of your brain that if I tickle it or if
I damage it we don't do this you people
come in from head injuries this is this
is the full set of data we have on well
not the
full set now because we have probes and
things but historically how do you know
what part of the brain controls what
it's from head injuries that people had
hmm you got hit over here you got hit
back here you got hit over here there's
a Language Center who's a facial
recognition Center there's the part of
you that is your understanding of self
if those parts of your brain gets
damaged you lose your language you lose
your facial recognition you lose
memories either short-term or long-term
we know these parts of your brain so to
say I am me and that's some special
spiritual entity as far as I can tell
it's electro chemical synapses firing in
your brain got it so it's giving you
this belief that you are something other
than just the chemistry and biophysics
of a brain matter what is making it fire
like what what is the what is the what
is asking it to do things what makes me
think to ask you a question so this is
consciousness and this is a huge
frontier now here's something I would
tell you no one else is gonna tell you
you ready I'm sure everybody's writing
books on a subject
it means we know nothing about it and
the more the literature there is make
sense the less we know about it that's
why people keep writing it go go to the
books if there's still bookstores go to
the bookstore look at the shelf on the
human mind oh the shelf after shelf now
look at this shelf of physics
there's no who does the gravity boom
because what because it is what it is
what is with it we're on to the next
thing we got this so the fact that
everyone and their cousin is writing a
book on consciousness yes evidence of
what we do not yet know I'm just saying
so are you saying that this is the
exciting little frontier spot where
we're at yes conscious what do you think
about consciousness I think about it all
the time and here's how I think about
its why do I wake up every morning as me
and not you
or someone else if we're just
consciousness you're saying if if if I
don't know I'm just saying why is it
that every day I wake up I mean what
makes that that and consider that
identical twins with identical DNA have
separate consciousness consciousness
they're separate they're not the same
people they have different thoughts they
might have similar desires or you know
their twin separated and they will draw
the same color car or whatever with as
they later discover that happens a fine
but I'm talking about
are you hungry in this moment that's
your consciousness telling you this act
in your twin just ate an hour ago your
twin is not having that same thought
this is the big challenge with the with
the transporter and Star Trek if I
disassemble your molecules and
reassemble them over there is your
consciousness part of that if you're
conscious it is even a transferable
entity right I don't know so and let me
ask a more blunt question is
consciousness even the right question to
ask we think it's the right question if
I posed the question what kind of cheese
is the moon made out of and you say yes
be cheese I think it's pretty so so you
don't you start posing and creating
experiments that are designed to test
for cheese but the moon is not made out
of cheese so you asked the wrong
question in the first place not every
question is a legitimate question and
when you're on the frontier you don't
even know what that question is you got
a nice you got a ticket on drum you've
got a tiptoe and ask in little bits is
the moon made of anything is it made of
atoms is it made of rocks what is it
made of how do I test that you got an
inch your way there
otherwise you'll bust out of the doorway
with a question you think it needs an
answer like what is the sound of one
hand clapping well just because you
assembled nouns and verbs
the right sequence to make a legitimate
sentence in the English language does
not make it an authentic sentence worthy
of scientific attention the same when I
think about consciousness I think about
like Neil are you your arms I control my
arms but if you lost them might still be
me that's right what about your heart
well Aristotle thought all emotion was
in the heart here's what I think about
often and that stayed with us through
like the Renaissance until we had some
understanding of brain it was like what
does your heart tell you your heart is
just pumping doesn't know anything about
anything it's left over from a time when
we thought all that our emotional center
was located in our heart that Aristotle
has a big have a lot to do with that
misinformation that misunderstanding so
so I was wondered if Aristotle said your
emotions are in your pancreas then I
wonder if on Valentine's Day images of
the pancreas or some other organ you
know it's just it's just by happenstance
that the heart stayed with us so then
there's there's another sort of you know
so if you if you didn't know from
someone has a pancreas just give it a
chance so it makes me think of chakras
it makes me think of energy centers when
you go into more of the you know Eastern
philosophies of you know the energy
centers of our you know root chakra
you know solar plex crown chakra all the
seven chakras like maybe the heart
operates with those thoughts so it's
that energy center giving you a feeling
do you believe in that so I'm not
convinced I mean I've seen the chakra
charts and other sort of Eastern ways of
observing and thinking about life and
the universe and I let me answer that
two ways I could I could first say
there's no way any bit of science has
ever found a way to justify that that's
too blunt let me be a little more a
little softer and that is it is possible
to have a philosophy about how something
works that's wrong yet there's still
benefit to be obtained from it so what
would be an example of that
what I what's a good example so let's
take the chiropractic for example okay
if you read the foundations of
chiropractic it's like got that right
but I'm writing that down don't ever go
to a chiropractor go look at the charts
that say everything about your body
emanates from spinal column vertebrate
okay you catch a cold there's a blind
into your vertebrae so manipulate the
vertebrae and everything everything is
to look at early writings about the
chiropractic arts okay so what happens
you go to a chiropractor
they you know they pop your back and
they manipulate it and it feels good
whether or not it cured your common cold
let's say about well there are not a
cured your cancer whether or not
anything else happened people still
derive some curative elements from it so
in science what we try to do is extract
what it is they're the essence of what
it is they're doing and only apply that
mm-hmm that's what we try to do it's
very reductionist but that's what it's
how we got civilization reductionist is
there's this whole thing the
reductionist if you're chewing on this
bark and your pain goes away well is it
the bark or is it some chemical in the
bark let me find out oh here's this
chemical it's Alaska it's it's it's it's
a seed of salicylic acid oh my gosh
that's aspirin
aspirin so here his appear is a lump of
bark and here's a pill what are you
gonna do you chew on them are gonna take
the bill I think because I found what's
in the bark that does it but you might
have had a whole philosophy about bark
that the tree has a spirit energy and
the tree that per tree in particular is
touched by the gods and you and it the
gods want you to feel better and to
relieve your pain so the gods put this
special magic potion in the bark and you
chew the bark and you're all better
I found the aspirin here it is go buy it
in the grocery store for two dollars and
so is it sad that I bypass the entire
cultural spiritual rituals of it I don't
think I don't think it's sad I'll tell
you why
look at how many rituals we still
participate in oh yeah and and they're
beautiful and they're sensitive and
they're reflective look at what Jews do
in in Passover there's a seder and in
the seder they leave an empty seat for
Elijah in Casey and had to unlock the
front door in case Elijah shows up at
your seder do they really think that's
gonna happen I don't think they really
think Elijah's coming I'm pretty sure
they're not let that person in but but
the ritual of it can be very communal
and there's so much of what binds us
socially that derives from ritual be it
religious ritual or some other cultural
ritual do you we play the national
anthem at the beginning of games that
kind of binds us all at the beginning of
sporting events if the Canadiens are
there we also play the Canadian national
anthem we you take off your hat you
salute you you hug on certain holidays
you Thanksgiving we have Turkey yes I'm
not here to judge the value of those
rituals scientifically I'm here to
celebrate the value
those rituals culturally I don't have a
problem this kind of gets me into the
fields oh by the way there's some sorry
so to interrupt no go for it oh don't
lose I thought there's some rituals that
might be hurtful to you
sure okay and ice why withdraw the wine
I say if my region let's do that if it's
hurtful to you or to myself I want
someone to step in
I'd want someone to theirs in Catholic
there's some Catholic and traditions
particularly in central South America
where an Easter people will go on their
knees in the way that Jesus was carrying
the cross to suffer and like Jesus
suffered and I thought Jesus suffer so
we don't have to suffer i man no meat on
Friday was enough right yeah so no it's
not just no meat on Friday fish on
Friday because they were in that place
when that rule came in it was the
fishermen were not getting as much
business as the rest of the food
producers and the Pope got his message
from God that one day we can have to eat
fish so it's not a no meat day it's a
fish day so you are still eating dead
animals but it kept the fisherman yeah
so that's how you get messages god man I
thought it was because meat was a luxury
it's like so like pulling back from the
luxury it's always been a luxury for
sure it's very expensive to produce meat
right so then what the hell did Moses
what what's the deal with Moses well
knowing that take a man who says thou
shalt not eat meat on Friday maybe
that's in the 11th through the 15th
commandment that have lost all typically
where did his information come from for
the Ten Commandments well so what's
interesting to me is you know people
people need rules
yeah without rules you know it's sad
that we need rules but it's not that we
need rules well of course we need rules
but we need threat of punishment for not
following rules and for some people I
think prison isn't enough right and so
if
there's a higher power above us all that
could damn you to hell for eternity that
might keep you in line okay my issue
with the Ten Commandments was that like
why is that shalt not kill like number
six I'm thinking that should have been a
little higher big of a deal is killing
or or graven images or one God first you
know I'm thinking this up that a little
if I were dead if I had my druthers plus
depending on which version of the Bible
you use thee the commandments are not
exactly in the same order as each other
so there's some various but in none of
them is that's what I kill number one
yet that is the highest level
transgression we have in modern
societies so we have made a judgment on
the rest of the command saying no we
don't really care about the graven image
no don't bear false witness that's a bad
thing but we're not gonna punish shoot
and damned you forever for that so human
element humans decided marijuana was
illegal until recently till it was not
it's just a human decision right so
morality is actually this moving target
I want to claim that it's a bounced it
back and forth target but morality if
you look over time has evolved to be
sort of not in every place of course but
we're always evolved to be more
inclusive and more forgiving and more
accommodating and so so more Allium it's
a huge philosophical frontier where do
you get morality from and many people
will say like it we get it from my
religion no you actually don't you
actually don't
what you've done is cherry-picked your
religion and pick the things that make
most sense in modern society and they
say I get my morality from religion well
you did you use secular reasoning to
filter out so many of the statements
that are made in the Bible especially
the Old Testament for example where you
know it's if your children disobey you
you should stone them well no we're not
doing that
we're not i'm sovereignty
the jail threat okay by the way mom and
dad that's the gym okay we would we are
not going to stone our children yeah
before disobeying us we will now they
say no one happened let's go to the next
one
okay if by the way this section of the
Bible is in Leviticus also contains the
one where you shouldn't be homosexual
okay this is the same section of the
Bible that says you know you should
stone your children if they disobey okay
so we are you a cherry-picking right and
so what's happened and plus the Bible
was used to justify slavery why because
nowhere in the Bible older New Testament
is slavery objected to it is passive or
supportive in its attitudes towards
slavery so what so most of what
justified slavery over so many years
came from people's readings of Scripture
there are some other readings of
Scripture where you got to go to the New
Testament for this and you got to go to
Jesus and it's do you want to others [ __ ]
there's doing you know there's this sort
of the Golden Rule kind of thing and
other ways to think about the Quakers
were totally anti ed Quakers are
Christian totally anti-slavery from the
get-go
mmm-hmm from the get-go and they were
driven by religious means and you have
the whole civil rights movement which
had a secular atheistic dimension to it
but that was not talked up in the press
a philip Randolph and others they were
atheists someone who even like communist
atheist communists who were there for
the worker and workers rights and this
not the not the capitalist right so that
the workers right Martin Luther King was
the one that the press focused on
because we were there's still a cold war
and you can't have heroes who are
sympathizers with the Communist Party so
so Martin Luther King gets the the
positive attention from the press but
but he gets his roots from the Bible and
and this so so you you're cherry-picking
to suit what your needs are at the top
you know a lot about the Bible what a
transmat new tests kind of blowing my
being a scientist so you're gonna have
to explain to me how you know so much
I tell you why yeah please I was minding
my own business
just doing my astrophysics okay really
I was just I was just mind my own
business in the corner I got my calculus
books and bikes all right and people
would come up to me and say calculus I
want you to make sure you know that okay
do you be a little more comfortable with
infinity if you took calculus okay see
there you go can I afford a private
tutor big calculate a private calculus
tutor and you'll come out of that saying
I'm good with infinity so people started
asking me as you study the universe have
you found God does studying the universe
make you closer to God I think any dude
out there or so no just spiritually
philosophically are you yes some might
wonder if it's literal behind the moon
so so I would have answers but I
realized if I'm an educator I can't just
give any answer off-the-cuff it needs to
be informed it needs to be researched
knowledge is power it needs to be I need
to do my homework before I start
speaking on this topic and respect so I
started buying the books like but you
know the Torah and so that's just purely
the Old Testament I translated of course
does I can't beat Hebrew and then I got
the you know King James Newton you know
New Testament and then I got modern
translations of the New Testament that
use modern language and then I got a now
assist of the Bible's and then I got yes
well I mean I mean I said I know what's
in and I went to some yeah passages that
are more I mean they're places you don't
this there's the whole section of the
Bible where's who begat who that's not
scintillating reading so you skip over
that I'm sorry it's okay
okay I'm forgiving you producer for
giving me away with your information
about the Bibles okay so you find places
a place in the Bible for example where
the value of pi equals three point zero
what do they got it wrong yeah yeah they
got it wrong
yeah they tell you why I have to in in 1
Kings 7 that part of the Bible they're
describing King Solomon's property the
castle and the his palace and the
surrounding grounds and there's a pond
there and here's the statement you ready
the pond is round on all sides 30 cubits
around 10 cubits across the value of pi
is the ratio of the circumference of a
circle to its diameter so 30 divided by
10 goes 3.0 now had they said 31 cubits
around because fractions and decimals
weren't a big thing but and 10 cubits
across they would be much better they've
got 3.1 and it's a hey they got a fig
they got an understanding there and the
best estimates of PI of the day what's
not much different but there was a
better estimate of Pi than 3.0 the
Babylonians have 3.14 and that preceded
the writing of that section of the Bible
so my only place so I've learned all of
this and so now when people start asking
me do I see God do I know God well how
do I know the science is long and the
Bible is right which is which I can
engage that conversation in an informed
and I'd like to even declare respectful
way I'm not here to bash people I'm here
to just share pic with people what is
objectively true in the world are you
spiritual so that's good cuz right was
religious yes I would I use versus like
the Mart is like the fastest growing
community to community I'm a cult leader
so these are people who these are people
who spiritual people
I wouldn't call them spiritualists
because those in a day were people who
talk to dead talk to the dead
so our spirits of spiritual mediums they
would talk so if you are spiritual today
that means you feel there's something
out there beyond what we know could be a
god but you're not affiliated with any
organized religion that is the
fastest-growing
oh but so let me back that up people not
affiliated with any religion would
include atheists that's the fastest
growing community
I saw a religion called um nism is omnes
'm which is the belief that there is
that none of the no religions are true
but there's truth within all of them
mmm-hmm I would say that's me I kind of
I've always been very skeptical okay but
now you have to go you have to visit
each religion and find out what is true
- and then staple all that together to
get your organism and that's hard let me
back up I can tell you certain things
that are objectively false the earth is
not 6,000 years old I got this one okay
why do people have denial about like the
science of the age of the earth or age
of the you know how long humans have
been around and there's I have thought a
lot about this and I've concluded there
are three truths
yes I'm ready yeah three truths okay are
you ready yes all right sorry the three
kinds of truths not three answers okay
hmm one time truth is an objective truth
this is what is researched and
established by the methods and tools of
science this is what is true whether or
not you believe in it it's how we make
electricity work
it's how the physics of your cars you
drive works
it's how earth moves around the Sun it's
how energy from the Sun powers the
ecosystem and the biosphere those are
objective truths you
you can argue it but it won't matter if
you argue it it's true whether or not
you argue it's it's your it's your you
know okay so in the bookstore correct
second kind of truth it's a personal
truth these are truths that are true to
you they are true down in your bones
Jesus is your Savior Muhammad is your
prophet these you know this is true no
matter what and no one is going to take
it from you at least not in a free
society no one is going to take that
from our religion and our religious or
faiths and our our beliefs in our faiths
are constitutionally protected conduct
of American citizens it's what attracted
so many immigrants over the decades
where they were the religion was
persecuted where they were and they come
here they knew they wouldn't be
persecuted okay hence the religious
melting pot that we actually are okay
so that's your truth but watch what
happens the only way you can get me to
share that truth is by some intense bout
of persuasion or by threat of force
violence or death I have a different
personal truth than you do you require
that I share your personal truth we will
go to war over that you know why because
my personal truth tells me that your
personal truth is false mm-hmm most
religions its most monotheistic really
the great monotheistic religions have as
part of their tenant that other
religions are false right
so each one says the other one is false
and curiously our country protects that
it allows you to say that your belief is
true and everyone else is false and it
allows me to say the same damn thing
about you so you live in a community
where your folks are and you go to your
worst place of worship on Saturday or
Sunday and I go to
I pray five times a day to Mecca I do
that with my community and by the way we
both work together in the same office
okay historically you didn't have places
like the United States and whole legions
would fight the Crusades the just look
at what people did to each other because
their personal truths were not shared by
others yes yes but yes yes it used to be
a daily thing now we have wars over you
know access to resources and things well
yeah well and some other Dogma that
might have arisen like Nazism or you
know that you can have Dogma oh but
Dogma is equally as bad yes sorry
dogma can drive you to war just as
readily as strongly held religious
beliefs because Dogma is this is true no
matter what you tell me yeah and that
doesn't have to involve God that you'd
involve any other strong beliefs strong
belief
okay it means you're not susceptible to
conversation and a new idea that could
put you in a new place you are sealed
off from arguments of reason so that's a
personal truth there's a third kind of
truth it's a political truth this is
what you think is true because someone
repeated it to you often enough
programming program it's correct
what's finally watched the program for
the programming what is Hillary's first
name crooked Hillary told me the TV
totally so what I will say about these
three truths is in a pluralistic country
the pluralistic land if you are going to
make laws that apply to everyone it
seems to me you should base them on what
is objectively true and not is on any
one person's personal truth which would
then affect everybody else who doesn't
share
personal booty hmm and if you put it on
a political quote truth mm-hmm then that
will blow like the breeze some other
power rises up and they don't have
something else and now that person who
used to be your friend is now your enemy
let me tell political truths can evolve
the Republicans are not historically I
mean in in recent decades not known for
being cuddly with minority groups okay
if you look at how minority groups vote
generally it's not Republican yeah you
could say why well the policies are
might conflict with ideas Dada Dada not
fine do you know the first Republican
president was no oh he knows Abraham
Lincoln yeah Abraham Lincoln friend of
the slaves hmm Abraham Lincoln's the
first Republican president the
Republicans were the anti-slavery party
while the Democrats were perfectly fine
keeping slaves yeah lovely way to go no
wait a minute so what happens the South
had all the slaves so the slot the South
is not going to be Republican the South
with Democrats and they were Democrats
from the Civil War for a hundred years a
hundred years in the South they had Jim
Crow they had segregation they had all
of that and they were just fine with it
and from the 1960 through basically
President Reagan in the 1980s that
flipped the Republicans saw that they
can get a stronghold in the south by
altering their policies and saying yeah
we don't really wanna the Equality here
or whatever it was and keep this going
and they one-by-one they absorbed the
the Dixiecrats the Dixie Democrats
became Republicans
so I'm saying if you're gonna base your
life on political truths know that
someone else is defining for you what it
is you think is right and wrong and what
is true or not and as a academic and
especially as a scientist I don't want
anybody else doing my thinking for me
and political truths are someone else
telling you what to think and how to
think do you think I'm screaming at you
here I'm so yeah no it's good you know
it's some passion I love it just is so
anybody you think we need to think more
for ourselves I feel like I feel like
there's this is a wave of coming it's
kind of it's it's it's spirituality it's
hot buttons it's like think for
ourselves a little bit more do you feel
this do you think this is a good thing
I'd rather I agree but I'd rather say it
differently okay yeah you'd rather than
say think for yourself because sometimes
there's an expert who knows more about
something than you
okay and if you have reason to trust
that person you trust them okay if this
building is on fire and what was with 14
flights up and I say there's a sheet
over there and we can strap it to the
thing we could jump out the window and
glide to that thing
I bet you'll believe me because I'm
trained in physics and I know something
about eridan up you don't say oh no I
don't believe I don't okay goodbye
how'd you work out my race card for all
the physics that you know and so there's
the points where yes you'll trust
someone without having to question it
but I those extreme that's obviously a
contrived example but what you should do
is when someone is speaking to you a
pundit you should not just believe
everything they say you should wonder if
everything they say is true and use it
as an excuse to go back and do a google
search or go check on that statement or
go check on all of these things mm-hmm
and the act of checking you end up
learning yeah why is it that we live in
a world where no matter what grade
you're in
the last day of school in May or in June
you run down I'm stereotyping here you
run down the steps
toss your books in the air and say
school's out yeah you're glad I did that
very thing that school is out yeah you
are you what did we do to you in school
so that when school is out you glad
you're not in school
something is wrong what I want to have
happen is what we do in school is such
that on the last day school you say
school's out makes me I can't have to go
three months without learning anything
it's the only job in school is to learn
knowledge is power I believe that and
this reminds me of how I feel about food
when people like oh gosh I'm on a diet I
have to eat this healthy food all I want
is the pancakes in my cheat meal it's
like how about you change your psyche a
little bit and go man this is delicious
I'm gonna put a little of this seasoning
on it we have like the wrong thought
process for some things that we have now
culturally convinced ourselves that
certain things are good certain things
are bad when all we need to do is change
our point of perception that is true for
so many things and let me tell you my
thoughts about food I'm disturbed that's
too heavy a word I'm concerned that in
America we view food that has high
calories as bad when most of this world
does not even get their minimum calories
in a day we are so wealthy yes we have
so much access to food that a high
calorie food is considered bad and I
cringe every time I see that in here
because I think of empowerment is
millions what the number I forgot the
number
but it's millions nothing children
starve to death either big out of them
because not enough food or because of
malnutrition that comes from having not
having enough food like you can die just
because your your body eats its own
calorie content and they just drop dead
or you can be malnourished and then
you're susceptible to diseases that are
opportunistic under those situations I'm
telling you the United States might be
the only country in the world that has
overweight homeless people but they're
getting plenty of calories okay the
donuts are doing them just fine yeah and
so I is another thing I sensitive to
people who can't help themselves for
whatever reason whatever they got the
wrong hand dealt or they they need
motivation the people that step over
homeless person to go help a stray dog
there's a homeless human being that's
your species sitting right here that you
just ignored what are you doing now
don't get me wrong I love me some dogs
okay but if I have to rank how I'm going
to invest my time and energy and
resources it's gonna be to help people
and in there sure I'll help a couple of
dogs I don't have a problem with that so
what I'm gonna saying oh there's a dog
in trouble they're not even see the
homeless person oh my gosh
so it's an Outlook thing and I'll only
give here's what I do it just as a
matter of policy if I go to a restaurant
I eat well at a restaurant and I have a
doggie bag
mm-hm if I pass a homeless person they
get in a doggie bag yeah no matter how
expensive that food was were like
leftovers I can't wait for tomorrow
morning stakes knowing your ass exactly
exactly know it goes in the lap of the
homeless person but if I have my choice
of homeless person who's going to the
fittest person I see who's in the most
need right so yes outlook I think is
everything what are some other things
that you're passionate about make it be
they could be passions like that that
you you know it's not necessarily about
stars in the dark matter but you know
what other things
I guess I'm seeking what sounds like
it's passion but it's really just an
interest a deep interest yeah maybe this
passion
I'd like you know I like old books No
okay like okay get that get that digital
book reader out of here oh me too yeah
all the way you know do you realise a
physical book never runs out of
batteries did you know that ever it's
still there it even smells unique and
cool people ride unum it's fun I I have
books I I collect books they go back in
time that that capture a moment in our
collective thinking where we that pivot
in a moment in our collective thinking
where we have a new understanding of the
universe or our our place within the
universe and this allows me it's
humbling because you see the struggle
that's that people went through to get
something that we today just take for
granted yeah as though the knowledge on
wiki pages is handed down from on high
no somebody figured that out and it's
staying around here's the thing that
scares me about digital it's a click
away from being gone I think about my
bank account I'm like oh sure I don't
know what was the last book you read
uh-oh
so I I dip into a lot of books in
different ways but I think the last book
I read so I have several going right now
but the last book I finished was a book
I'd actually read long ago but I read it
again and it's Barry Goldwater's the
conscious of her conservative look at
you did she go into the conscious step
no but it's just it's just the brought
to mind uh because that's really what it
should have the conservative yeah yes so
Barry Goldwater was you know a very well
known and popular conservative
politician in the United States who
actually ran and lost four grand for
president and lost and this is during
the Cold War so in this book he's trying
to say what that conservative thinking
is better than liberal thinking and it's
better than communism I just I'd like
knowing how other people think sure I
would classify myself as
liberal in most ways that matters
socially
yeah probably fiscally centrist I would
say I'd like learning how conservative
people think and how they make decisions
and what's interesting people say tell
me all the books on your shelf and
they're expecting books to be all the
stuff that I already agree with that's
very smart of you what's always on the
other side I read it all the time that's
why I have a shelf of Bibles I have a
shelf of UFO sightings
I have a shelf of all don't worry I
won't ask universe
oh nice no nice of you I saw it and I
have I haven't read it yes yes a guy
from up at MIT I think wrote that or is
or is there another author do you
remember the author of this one um I
can't remember oh yeah so holographic
universe that's very freaky it's freaky
stuff that we might just be a
two-dimensional hologram like some other
reality I think the universe has told us
that anything that is possible may just
be likely and yeah we could just be
information contained in a membrane
surrounding some other volume and we
it's the illusion of a reality but in
fact we're just this holographic
projection of information yeah it's deep
it's very I mean like it took me a while
to read completely deep it's very
interesting and it makes you think it
makes you think in new ways about the
mind it makes you think about the power
of the mind really which is something
that's very intriguing to watch so let
me let me just this but really the power
of the mind let me disavow of that if I
may yeah okay yeah we figured out a lot
of stuff we've got art and music and
poetry in the Hubble telescope beeping
we've walked on the moon the human mind
is something else okay
do you know our closest genetic
relatives
yes you do yeah just say it yeah chimps
chimpanzees okay chimpanzees 99 and a
half percent identical DNA done yeah
yeah so why do they have every muscle
and every bone in the same place that we
do and they're comfortable you cross
your legs they're comfortable crossing
their legs sitting there and mean
another thing they have an itch they
scratch it you want to call it they call
okay
except they like termites and weird
stuff too okay I'm gonna ask you what
you going out of there so so the urge
and this is our ego doing this the urge
is to say what a difference that one and
a half percent makes it may be as low as
1% but it's small I don't remember the
exact number but it's what a difference
that one person it makes we have
civilization and the smartest chimpanzee
can stack boxes to reach a banana our
toddlers can figure that out I've seen
young children stack things well okay so
maybe allow me to pose you this question
maybe the difference between the human
and the chimpanzee at the 1% DNA is the
same small difference as between
stacking boxes to reach a banana and the
Hubble Space Telescope you're saying no
come on how could what do you say
obviously the telescope is much more
advanced than a monkey chimp figuring
out to stack box up you tell me you're
tend to say that okay now here's the
thought experiment imagine an oak
now here here's a simple sentence ready
okay Danika here you're flying back to
LA tomorrow you catch up a plane you fly
United out of Newark or wherever you
land five hours later and you have a
dinner engagement with friends at your
favorite restaurant okay use nothing in
that scent
that would make sense to a chimpanzee
what is an airplane what is you know 10
o'clock in the morning
what is it restaurant what the food just
comes to you what what is that where did
it come from what oh you have a whole
supply chain from farms and then the
chip would have no idea and that is the
simplest sentence you would other in the
day yeah okay
now imagine a life form and ambien even
I don't care some life form that is one
percent beyond us in DNA then we are
beyond the chimp the smartest of us
would be brought forth by this species
and they'll say but the role Stephen
Hawking forward and say this one is
slightly smarter than all the other
humans because he can do astrophysics
calculations in his head like little
Timmy over here who just came home from
alien preschool Oh Timmy isn't that key
you just derive principles of calculus
put it on the refrigerator Oh their
simplest thoughts would be in yeah
conceivable yeah to the most brilliant
human beings at only 1% difference in
DNA suppose were 5% 10% 50% a hundred
percent so I will not walk forward and
say look how smart we are I will not do
that
I rather wallow in how smart were not
relative to how smart we could be now we
have an advantage because we communicate
you can benefit from calculations done
by engineers and physicists who came
before you to drive a car fast you don't
have to invent that yourself there are
books
hmm Kindles today and they pass that
information forward Isaac Newton
invented calculus basically on a dare
and he did it before he turned 26 just
by the way by the way by the way so
we get to bankroll his his advances and
then they think of his rungs on a ladder
he built that with that rung right there
now I can climb up step on that and put
in the next ladder rung on the ladder
and then someone after me and someone
after them so our our species
collectively may be able to transcend
itself transcend the individual so do
you so if we can let's go let's go down
let's go down the alien path here okay
it's time so you talked about the 1% and
what if there was another species that
was 1% beyond and let's call that
another 1% do you believe that the
there's two parts of this that the human
body becomes something different a
different form as it evolves into DIF on
different to the 1% more 1% more 1% more
and then the second part of is do you
think that we're looking for the wrong
damn thing in space we're looking for us
but we live in this perfect environment
right this ecosystem that is used to
striving the cosmos like one little
thing changes and then something else
nothing exists here and it's all about
the air quality I mean a call of that
stuff matters critically to the life on
Earth so are we looking for the wrong
thing alright so our body is pretty
irrelevant to our brain when you're just
figuring stuff out mm-hmm I mean the
best evidence of that is Stephen Hawking
okay yeah these clothes yep yeah I win
that argument we got it so so so the
evolution of the body I don't think is
even relevant it's the evolution of the
mind that would get you to these new
places this extra 1% or 1% beyond that
or 1% beyond that you'd be nice if we
had eight limbs but we don't be nice if
we could regenerate limbs by the way
we're not some model of evolution news
can regenerate limbs noose if they if
they wrote The Tree of Life look they
put themselves at the top say we can
reach all those poor humans they lose a
limb they stuck that for the rest of
their lives
if we
owls we said we can fly in those poor
humans those suckers they canvas and
there did such crappy visions since they
need to wear these things on their eyes
just a sad thing what 10th as well as we
do you don't have sonar out of the box
bats or like you know sonar exactly so
so the mind is what would have to evolve
it now are we looking for the wrong
thing I don't think so
we are made with carbon-based life mmm
carbon on the periodic table of elements
which you may remember from chemistry
class periodic table carbon is the
stickiest of all the elements it can
make more kinds of molecules than all
other kinds of atoms combined Wow so if
you were to pick one atom off of that
table and base the diversity of life on
it it would be Cardinal it gives you the
most variation the most options the most
experiments are we looking for carbon
another planet well turns out carbon is
one of the most abundant elements in the
universe where the hell are all the
people not only that we've got oxygen in
us and nitrogen we are made out of the
most common ingredients there's a graph
I have that I saw that it shows the
percentage of what we have of each each
thing like my words thing this much
percent oxygen this much percent carbon
this percent yep phosphorus and that's
the most common ingredients in the
universe mm-hmm which is why we Stardust
it's know we start us not only that's an
aspect of why we're Stardust we're
Stardust because those elements the
heavy elements in particular the carbon
the nitrogen the oxygen the iron are
made in the cores of stars that explode
scatter that enrichment across the
galaxy allowing the next generation of
stars to have those elements that can
make planets and life so it's not simply
that we are in this universe the
universe is in us
yes we are not it's not just poetically
true it is literally true that we are
Stardust and so when we look for life in
the universe it's not unrealistic to
look for carbon-based life it's just not
it's and plus we have an example of it
here so how many of other ways might
there be to be alive there could be many
but if you have a limited budget and can
design only one experiment are you gonna
pluck at random one of these hundred
ways that life might be alive that
you've never tested before that you'll
have any evidence on are we gonna try
the one way we know that life does exist
so we wish self-aware of that limitation
but it's not a crazy limitation to to
operate on it's not so are aliens real
probably there's no reason we life
started on earth pretty quickly with
almost as quickly as the environment
allowed we have self-replicating life I
love about to about a hundred million
years I love the in the cosmos how you
go to the calendar
well the cosmic calendar I think that
traces back to the original cosmos with
Carl Sagan yeah yeah you know I know you
know Carl Sagan you have a good store
what's uh how did you tell me the story
about Carl Sagan because there's a
cosmos - coming out - right yeah yeah
we're still looking for a date for that
actually technically cosmos three that's
one's three Testament New Testament
cosmos - well get biblical about it fine
okay so yeah I was in high school I was
a geeky kid I knew you know I knew my
high school you're an astrophysicist
it's okay okay just be frank about it
okay ABB's oh you're very funny my high
school counts eight Nobel laureates
among its graduates what would you want
some of the water
which is the same as the country of
Spain so jump to saying so this is a
this is a fertile environment all right
it's not because the teachers
necessarily it's because realize how
much how much down time you spend doing
nothing between classes you know chasing
a love interest or you know throwing
high school now hormones are raging your
you know what else your study hall but
you're not really studying it's
lunchtime you're talking about at that
school we're talking about who might
have an equation named after them in the
downtime that's uh that's obviously that
doesn't make any sense that's just like
not even in the spectrum of thought it's
great it's great officially all of
humanity it's crazy and not only that is
how old I am I was uh the youngest
person who was formally trained in a
slide rule in us what is it slide rule
so this is this thing that helps you
calculate before calculators oh god
before calculators there was this device
somebody there before calculus yes there
was a beast BC before calculators no ecc
so there's a device that has the sliding
sliders in it and and they're it's
highly the numbers all throughout this
isn't an abacus isn't no no no it's way
better than a NAPA hey Cathy but not as
good as a calculator and so you slide
these AC I want to multiply 387 by 28
and you'd slide these things and you you
can get the answer okay it's called a
sliding one the bigger the slide rule
the more nuance your numbers can be
because you can then read between the
tick marks okay so in my high school Wow
you walk down the car door you know if
you had the biggest slide rule you a
badass okay because you put have it in a
holster can't carry anything else I came
in leather holsters I attach it to your
belt oh my god
you're not Brad to be the coolest gig
ever wait a minute
so so I'm in high school
and I apply to colleges and so I'm
admitted to this set of colleges which
includes Cornell and I've known since I
was nine through eleven that I'd like
that the universe in fact the universe
was calling me I had nothing to do with
it now high side note I had no choice
thank you so I'm there and I get a
letter in the mail from Carl Sagan he
was already famous he had been on The
Tonight Show he didn't get done cosmos
but he was already famous mm-hmm and I
got a letter from Crossout he didn't
know I don't know this man what is this
what it's cool I'll write some paper a
theory
Lotso Lotso Lotso I did write a paper
and published in the journal my senior
and ice of the Bronx High School of
Science
I was energy of a physical sideshow but
that's not relevant to this there's just
more geeky stuff that one does in high
school okay oh by the way just so you
know in that high school is is it's
actually a regular high school just
shifted towards the geek end of the
spectrum sounds really regular so we had
we had jocks but they were geek jocks
that we had geeky people but they were
really really geeky people so and we had
bullies but they would geek bullies you
know where'd you fall in
I was geek jock good job yeah what'd you
play I wrestled I was undefeated I'm
captain of the team dang well that's
that high school got to college not so
much get to college wrestle these boys
from Nebraska oh yeah
okay we've got another situation so I
say call that farm strong farm strong
very good very good so I knew when when
I was not in the right what they're
asking in calm but no I still wrestle
because I didn't care that I want I just
enjoy the sport and I joined knowing
that if you lost it's because they were
better than you and you can know what to
do you can't blame it on anybody is what
it is you okay so why did I take that
hold diverse oh so I'm there in high
school I get the ladder from Carl site
opened up it says dear Neil the
admissions office showed me your
application to college and knowing that
they admitted you I want to help you
decide whether you want to come to
Cornell would you like to come visit my
labs when you said you'd come to the
interview with me I'm like so I'd love I
did double-check Mike he's known his way
right so I I'd like doing people's
podcasts in their early days I love
doing it okay just to just to help earth
more places where people can learn and
hear intelligent conversation held by
curious talented people so I just like
helping to birth people's podcasts so I
Carl took you on as a young
that's what us so here's what oh by the
way I only now learned that you came to
one of my public talks and so just so
you know it's authentic that this
interest is real it's not just okay well
she was a fan I guess I guess I'd better
know it was pure just want you to know
okay so I so I wrote him back as he yeah
but yeah so I visited him he met me
outside there was a weekend and it was a
look like who's gonna snow this is ethic
in New York or it snows all the time
most think 11 months of the year 11 11
and a half months of the year snowing
and cloudy so I'm very taking up to the
to my app shows me the lab shows in the
department I'm
in his office and this was the coolest
thing oh my gosh he doesn't even look
back
he's behind his desk and he reaches
behind him and pulls out a book and as
one of the books he wrote I said that's
badass
I'm sorry that's just badass you know
you have to look and a book you pick out
is and he signed it to me says dear
near-future astronomer I still have that
book and at the end he's taking me back
to the bus station it actually began to
snow and he says look if the bus doesn't
come through here's my home phone you
come spend the night with my family and
leave in the morning could the bus no
said that the bus didn't come first
people told me but no I was more honest
than that then my lesson from that was
that because I said to myself if I'm
ever as remotely famous as Carl Sagan I
will treat students the way he has
treated me and I could be on the phone
you know Barack okay I got to call you
back I got a student you know at the
door and and eventually I'd written
enough books so that and so when I'm in
the presence of students it's a sense of
duty and obligation I don't like that
word cuz it sounds like it's a chore but
it's a sense of duty is a better word
where the torch of science has to be
carried forward lest it become
extinguished and we live in the darkness
so then I know I've taken a lot of your
time and I think this is a good lead-in
to like the final thought final kind of
question although I have more like never
mind but that's for part two but what is
the point of all this
you know what is the point you say
you're you you want to give back to
students and that's important to you
what is the point of life are you really
asking what is the meaning of life or is
your question what difference to you
what are we here to do yeah you feel
called to help people you feel oh no I
can't I feel called to to discover the
universe but in there if someone wants
to also do that yeah I feel compelled
but if no one else wanted to do it I
don't I'm not gonna force anyone to like
the universe no but if you like it or if
because I said something you do want to
do science yeah I feel some duty I feel
some some sense of accountability for
someone's interests if they saw cosmos
and then they want to assign things I so
I feel some responsibility there well
then maybe the first question is how do
we how do we take science and how do we
make sure that that stays relevant
relevant and expanding so what we need
is a reality show where you get someone
who's in denial of science then
overnight you take everything out of
their life it's a space program and
thermal physics and electric electrical
engineering and so there it is you I
think earth is flat okay so you don't
get to fly in an airplane because you
might fly off the edge of the earth okay
so you will travel nowhere don't get me
started so I think we need a reality
show where we take science away from
science deniers and what you do is you
have to put a limit to that because
there's a level at which you can take
away science would they would just be
dead they would have died in childbirth
they would have died of some curable
disease so you say I'm gonna be nice to
you and not take away so much science
that you'd be six feet under right now
so I don't I just made that up on the
spot mm-hmm but yeah it's a problem what
you need is
people who are in charge because in a
free country
it's your right should not be
scientifically literate at all just
don't control anything that can affect
the health wealth and security of other
people because innovations in science
technology engineering and math will be
the roots of the future of our health
wealth and security if you don't know
that you might as well just move back to
the cave because that's where we're
gonna be anyway
now why are we alive why we here what's
the point here's some motivation for you
okay got my pen back huh all right the
human genome can combine in trillions of
ways to make a human what that means is
well so now put a pin in that how many
humans have ever been born latest
estimates it's about 80 billion
trillions is a way bigger number than 80
billion mm-hmm okay
taking a cue from a passage in a book
written by Richard Dawkins the biologist
evolutionary biologist one day we're all
gonna die
in this sad when someone dies however
not enough of us spend time celebrating
the fact that we were alive at all we as
individuals are collectively at all
individually you are lucky that you get
to die because ktml active most humans
who could ever exist never will
there's been more i think i've heard you
say it there's been more humans that
have not come into existence than do
exist
by far and so the fact that you existed
all is against stupefying odds of who
gets born and who does not realizing
this you are you I am me we are alive we
get to die and to get to die means you
get to live any moment you spend
squandering those moments you are alive
does disrespect to all those who will
never even be born so every day I wake
up I've got I want to make the world a
better place today for my having been in
this world than it was yesterday I want
to learn something new which empowers me
to make decisions that are more nuanced
deeper more informed than I could have
made yesterday and I want to celebrate
being alive even if you are sick even if
you are terminal you still got to live
when trillions of people will never even
be born so live every one of those
moments
tell me now what would be your greatest
celebration of being alive tell me what
your celebration would look like what's
your best day like give me like
fireworks of like no no here I'm alive
here it is you ready me that assumes
it's what that's captured in one moment
yeah but if that no but it's the sum of
it all the sum of it all so here's gonna
be my happiest moment and I won't even
be alive to see it but they chisel my
tombstone
my sister has written in her notes what
I wanna let you my tombstone and it's a
quote from the great educator Horace
Mann and it is be ashamed to die until
you have scored some victory for you
you very inspirational now now the
universe is inspirational I'm just
channeling that fact well it's been
something that's been always intriguing
to me and overwhelmingly amazing I'm
honored and flattered that you came to
one of my talks thank you
oh and I mean the cosmos was like a mind
expansion education on where we came
from the simplicity down to the
subatomic level all the way there and I
loved it and I can't wait for cosmos
three thank you like to meet you thank
you so much that's not gonna save our
life those swinging to say that again
now be ready for it
there you go okay thanks thanks Neil
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it and also thank you so much
Trevor Hall for the awesome music if you
liked what you heard today and you want
to hear more please click on the
subscribe button
you